foreign
welcome to this new video of Simply
learn on what is phantom but to
understand Phantom crypto precisely
let's take an example imagine that Alice
wants to send money to her friend Bob
who lives on the other side of the world
instead of using a slow and expensive
traditional method Alice uses fandom
cryptocurrency to send the money
now Phantom's fast and secure blockchain
technology processes the transaction in
just a few seconds and the money is
transferred directly to Bob's wallet Bob
can then easily exchange the fandom
tokens for his local currency and access
the funds overall Phantom cryptocurrency
offers a reliable and efficient way to
send money anywhere in the world without
relying on intermediaries or worrying
about delays or high fees
now technically speaking Phantom or FTM
is a cryptocurrency that operates on its
own blockchain platform
it aims to provide a fast scalable and
secure infrastructure for decentralized
applications and smart contracts
Phantom was designed to address some of
the common issues associated with
blockchain platforms such as high
transaction fees slow transaction speeds
and limited scalability it uses a
technology called lasis protocol which
enables Pastor consensus and allows for
parallel processing of transaction
the Phantom ecosystem also includes
several other components such as virtual
machine for executing smart contracts a
decentralized exchange for trading
cryptocurrencies and staking mechanism
that rewards users for holding and
securing the network overall Phantom
aims to provide a reliable and efficient
platform so now that you know what is
phantom let me tell you how it works
so Phantom basically works on that or
directed acyclic graph in dag there is a
set of systems in a network who
constantly interact with each other back
and forth about transactions that they
have using this concept they agree on
what The Ledger is and what data should
be stored on them throughout the time
this confirms the finality the
transaction and make sure it's time
effective preceding that Phantom works
with consensus mechanism now Phantom
follows a special proof of stake model
leases laces only have 50 validators and
to become a validator you will need to
at least take 1 million Phantom coins
which is currently a lot of money but
you can definitely delegate your Phantom
coins to any other validator whom you
trust and that validator can actually
participate in dag on your behalf and
you can then easily earn rewards and to
make that possible you can also stake as
low as one Phantom however you must
select a lockup period because the
longer you stay your token the more
rewards you get in return now to
understand the functionality of phantom
let me take you through the tokonomics
of phantom
now did you know that popular blockchain
project Phantom is using an Innovative
model to grow its ecosystem with nearly
3.2 billion FTM tokens in circulation
the project has adopted an inclinatory
approach that decreases as more users
join the platform to further incentivize
your adoption the platform using a
whopping 20 of the total inflation
rewards for notes while giving the rest
as incentives for users contributing to
the overall growth of the network
these incentives include negligible
transaction fees and rewards for users
who actively participate in their
networks development so why not join the
Phantom Network today and start reaping
the benefits of this exciting ecosystem
well let me tell you Phantom tokens were
distributed in the following way 40
token sale 30 Market development 15
advisors or contributors and 15 Phantom
team and Founders so now the question
arises how to buy Phantom now you can
buy Phantom on decent lives exchanges
like etoro Kraken pivot and Maxi well
this was all about what is phantom I
hope you found it interesting and
informative if you like this video then
please do share it with your friends and
subscribe to our channel for more such
interesting content and if you have any
questions regarding this video then
please feel free to ask away in a
comment section our team will reach out
to you as soon as possible till then
keep learning thank you
like this video subscribe to the simply
learned YouTube channel and click here
to watch similar videos turn it up and
get certified click here